in less than two years my administration
has accomplished more than almost any
Administration in the history of our
country America's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
Iran's leaders so chaos death and
destruction they do not respect their
neighbors or borders or the sovereign
rights of nations
instead Iran's leaders plundered the
nation's resources to enrich themselves
and to spread mayhem across the Middle
East and far beyond the or going tragedy
in Syria is heartbreaking our shared
goals must be the de-escalation of
military conflict along with a political
solution that honors the will of the
Syrian people in this vein we urge the
United Nations LED peace process be
reinvigorated but rest assured the
United States will respond if chemical
weapons are deployed by the Assad regime